[موسيقى]
الموقف الاردني ثابت وايضا يتناسب
والتصعيد الموجود في هذه الحرب والاباده
التي تقوم بها اسرائيل في غزه والتضييق
الذي يتم ايضا بالضفه لانه مسار موازي
ايضا في السياسات الاسرائيليه المتعسف
والمتوحشه تجاه اهلنا في فلسطين عموما كان
الموقف الاردني يرت الثلاث اثافي وهي وقف
الحرب ايصال المساعدات
واستعاده المسار السياسي القائم على حل
الدولتين والذي يؤكد الذي ينتهي في
النهايه الى دوله فلسطينيه على حدود عاصمه
القدس على حدود الرابع الرابع من حزيره
المساله ليست هي بند على اجنده السياسه
الاردنيه انما هي قضيه اردنيه مهمه كما هي
القضيه ال فلسطينيه مهمه لاهلها هي ايضا
بالنسبه للاردنيين وهذا الامر ايضا ينعكس
من خلال ايضا المواقف الشعبيه الاردنيه
على مستوى الشارع الاردني بكافه اطيافه
اردن كل فتره بتعرض لحملات
تشويه مقصوده ممنهجه حسابات طبيعي انه
الاردن لما يقوم بهذه الادوار المتعدده
المختلفه على مستوى الدبلوماسيه التي
يقودها جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني
والتاثير اللي خلقته جلاله الملك رانيا
وايضا مشاركه ولي العهد والاميره سلم في
عمليات الانزال اضافه للقوى السياسيه
وتصريحات دوله رئيس الوزراء وايضا نائب
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه الاستاذ ايمن
الصف هذه الحيويه ايضا عند المجتمع
الاردني اللي بيتفاعل مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه والمجتمع الاردني صانع تاثير
في هذا المزاج العالمي والمؤثر تجاه
القضيه فلسطينيه الدبلوماسيات غربيه اصبحت
تردد مفردات اردنيه نحن نعتقد ان ال ما
يجري هو جزء من النظال الفلسطيني في سبيل
الوصول الى حقوقهم هذه الحقوق تم قضمها
وتم انهائها وتم التعاطي معها بشكل سلبي
وبشكل وحشي وبشكل ممنهج في التدمير
والقضاء على الامل
للناس اذا ارادت اذا اراد الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واراده اسرائيل ان ترى المنطقه
بشكل افضل عليها ان تتقدم اكثر نحو السلام
هذه الحكومه الموجوده في اسرائيل حكومه
متطرفه حكومه يمينيه اتخذت قرارات على
مستوى الكنيست بعدم عوده العمال
الفلسطينيين الى الخط الاخضر او ال 48
وهذول اكثر من
175000 عامل فلسطيني بياثروا على الحياه
بالضفه الغربيه وشكلوا قوه اقتصاد كبرى
معدل اجورهم تقريبا 400 مليون دولار هذول
هم بينشروا الاقتصاد الفلسطيني اسرائيليه
تتحدث عن مواجهات مع الاردن هي التي تقوض
السلام مع الاردن السلام اللي مهم بالنسبه
لها اكثر ما هو مهم بالنسبه للاردن
والاردن خياره الاستراتيجي كان السلام
ومازال لكن اسرائيل هي التي تعمل على نقض
هذا السلام و واده يمكن استمعت الى
نتنياهو يقول انه انا اللي وقفت حلم
الدوله الفلسطينيه
يعني ها هو شكل اسرائيل المتطرفه في ظل
هذه الحكومه امامهم فرصه انهم يغيروا
العالم ويغيروا صورته منهم باستعاده مسار
السلام واعطاء الفلسطيني حقوقهم هذا ما
نقوله والاردن رفع هذا الشعار استعاده
المسار السياسي لموضوع التفاوض وموضوع
اعاده الحقوق الفلسطينيه والدوله
الفلسطينيه في جانب اللي هو الاشاعات اللي
تفضلتي عنه حول ما يمر بالاردن اول مره
قالوا عن الطيارات اللي بتجي من الولايات
المتحده عبر مطارات اردنيه ثم الحديث عن
النقل ثم الحديث عن الانزال قالوا انه
الانزال الاردني هذا بينزله اجهزه تجسس يا
اخي في ناس كاره انه الاردن يشتغل ما بده
الاردن يتضامن مع الاخوان في فلسطين بده
ايانا ندخل حرب بحسابات يعني هو يريدها
وفي ناس يعني لا يريد للاردن ان يكون
مستقر
كان في البدايه عمليه الاجلاء هي السماح
بخروج الاردنيين وغير الاردنيين يعني خاصه
الرعايا الاجانب كان ايضا محتجزين الى ان
سمح
باخراج
الغير زيين من القطاع عبر معبر رفح وهذا
كان يواجه صعوبه كل الدول كانت تواجه
صعوبه في اجلاء رعاياها الاردن على دفعات
تم اجلاء مجموعات كبيره تقريبا اكثر من
600 مواطن اردني تم اجلائهم هناك اعداد
تتزايد لانه مش مسجلين بعض الناس بكونوا
وقد يزيدوا ويسجلوا في الايام القادمه
العدد الان سجلوا او ثبتوا وجودهم في قطاع
غزه تقريبا اكثر من 104
[موسيقى]
اردني
الاردن بيستورد كميات مش كبيره مؤثره في
استهلاكه ولا باحتياطي لكن نحن حريصين على
علاقتنا مع العراقي الشقيق تم بعض الحشو
على الحدود الاردنيه سابقا بدايه الحرب و
يعني حاولت ان تقطع وصول هذه الصهاريج
اللي نن ما بنظر لمساله انها علاقتنا مع
العراق ما بتخص بانه بيجي صهاريج نفط منهم
او لا نن بيهمنا استقرار العراق بيهمنا
تكون العلاقه متميزه معه وتم اتصالات على
اعلى مستوى وعادت هذه الاريج ل الامداد
والوصول للاردن الاردن يتعاقد مع شركه
امريكيه في موضوع الغاز ال نستورده من حقل
الشمال
بسعر معين وهذا لم يتغير عليه شيء التغيير
صار في الحقل اللي في الجنوب وهذا الامر
ايضا اعلنوا عن وقف الضخ منه حتى للاخوان
في مصر
وتم فيما بعد اذا تم اعاده الضغف فانه تم
ليس بالكفاءه التي كان عليها اللي بنسبه
50% بالنسبه للحقل الشمالي احنا عننا
ارتباطات وعلاقات مع شركه نوبل انيرجي
الامر مستمر ودوله رئيس وزراء صرح بانه
هذا امر مرتبط يعني بتعاقدات
سابقه واتفاقيات تجاريه لا علاقه لها
بالمسار الموجود اليوم بحقل الجنوب وهو
منفصل عنه
[موسيقى]
صحيح الاقتصاد الاردني تضرر تضرر بشكل
كبير وكما قلت لك يمكن في ظل هذه
الميزانيه الصعبه الاردن بقدم دعم بملايين
الى اشقائنا في فلسطين تضرر بالقطاع
السياحي تضررنا بدوره الاقتصاد تضررنا ب
المقاطعه بتاثر اليوم اللي هي خي للناس
الاضراب اللي تم ايضا اثر على دوره
الاقتصاد الاردن القوي هو الاردن الذي
يساعد اشقائنا في فلسطين و كثير دعوات
مرات بتصير احنا بحترم اراء الناس وبنقدر
تعبيرهم عن الغضب لكن نتمنى ان تكون هنا
دعوات تفيد غزه وتجعل الاقتصاد الاردني
اكثر قوه ليساعد اهلنا في غزه وفلسطين
بشكل عام الاردن يحتضن اعداد كبيره من
الفلسطينيين من طلاب الجامعات من المرضى
من الذين يمرون وتتقطع بهم السبل ولا
يستطيعون النزول الى فلسطين او العوده الى
غزه في عدد كبير من المرضى اللي بيتعالجوا
بالاردن من قطاع غزه ما رجعوا من سنتين
مثلا في مركز حسين لسرطان ويتكفل المركز
باقامتها وعلاجهم وباستمرار
هذا لا يحدث في الاردن ولا يحدث في غيره
من الدول بالتالي نن ننظر انه تكون
المبادرات يكون الخلق الاردني والابداع
الاردني في ايجاد مبادرات وال الشعب
الاردني غير عاجز عن ابداعات في ازمنه
ضيقه وصعبه عليه تمكن من ان يكون اكثر
اشراقا واكثر منعا واكثر قوه في الاقتصاد
بنقول هذا جهد المقل اي والانفاق في العسر
يكون ابلغ مرات من الانفاق في اليسر عندما
تساعد انسان او او جار فما بال كيف اخ
وشقيق ونسيب وسهر و وانسان اردني ومواطن
نن نتحدث عن اردنيين موجودين في قطاع غزه
بتتحدث عن اردنيين في الضفه بتتحدث عن
مدارس بتتحدث عن مستشفيات بتتحدث عن خبز
بتتحدث عن قمح بتتحدث عن معادله اردنيه
صعب تفسيرها للعالم اعتقد من الصعب ان
نقول في الاردن للعالم ماذا تعني لنا
فلسطين في كثير ناس ممكن ما بيجبوا هذا
الكلام وفي كثير قوى سياسيه غاضبه تريد من
الاردن ان يذهب اليوم ويدخل بحرب مع
اسرائيل لكن الاردن لديه حسابات دوله
لديها اقتصادها لديها وجودها الذي تحافظ
عليه لديها مكتسبات التي يجب ان تحافظ
عليها شقاء الفلسطينيين يقولون نريد
الاردن ان يكون امنا وسالما
n